I think I'm gonna start a series called what's in my Homeschool Bag?
So I'm in our school room right now,
which I do love.
But the biggest fun of homeschooling is that we can be on the go.
So I always have this little bag packed.
We've got Scissors, glue, pens,
pencils, crayons, etcetera,
anything they might need, and then whatever we're working on.
So today, what are we gonna work on?
Today we are starting a unit on who was Walt Disney.
The who was books are some of my favorite resources.
And my kids, for social studies,
they picked Walt Disney cause we're going to Disney World soon
and they wanna know how the man,
the myth, the legend came to be.
We've also started a unit on neurology,
brain structure and neurodiversity.
I am neurodiverse. My daughter is undiagnosed,
but definitely neurodiverse.
It starts off with showing you the structures of the brain
and the different parts of the brain.
And then it goes into things like anxiety,
depression, and neurodiversity.
And then we're also gonna be doing our phonics work today
because we're still working on our workbooks from last year,
and I am determined to finish them.